the issue however is in the instance of
Israel often times what they're saying
is they've built a weapons Depot and a
military base under a hospital we've
given them a warning and we're going to
take it out I say okay do I take
Israel's word for it well the one thing
I can say is Israel at least is saying
that much we are trying to avoid killing
civilians well okay I don't trust
governments right everyone's got an
agenda but I can accept that you then
have Barack Obama's ridiculous
non-science excuse for killing an
American citizen in Yemen they've never
answered for and that's evil but this is
overtly celebrating the tactic of
targeting civilians intentionally yeah
you know that's black lives matter Max
Blumenthal he was on last night and he
said that these guys were paratrooping
into to hit a military Target and landed
next to the Target in the music festival
and it was an attack of opportunity as
opposed to a target a target of
opportunity I don't know if it really I
don't know how much matters wait wait
like I mean if he's being factual he's
being factual